YEAH ITS GOING DOWN. YOU KNOW
HOW I GET DOWN.
FUNKMASTER FLEX AND BE CLEAR ALL
THE BIG DOGS KNOW
THAT MY MAN FISTICUFF
RULES THE STREETS.
AND IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
JOINT, "TURN MY HEADPHONES UP",
YOU NEED TO GET WITH IT,
ACT LIKE YOU WANT IT.
WATCH OUT FOR YOUR MIND,
ALL THIS IS HOT.
WHAT !
UNH !
TURN MY HEADPHONES UP !
I'M SERIOUS, NIGGA,
TURN THEM SHITS UP !
TURN 'EM UP !
HOLD UP...
I'M SERIOUS, NIGGA,
I CAN'T HEAR OUTTA THIS EAR,
TURN MY HEADPHONES UP.
I STABBED
A BROTHER IN THE NECK
WITH A BUTTER KNIFE
FOR FISTICUFF.
JUST 'CAUSE.
IT AIN'T GOIN' PLATINUM,
IT'S GOIN' DOUBLE URANIUM, SON.
URANIUM, YA HEARD ?
WE POPPIN' BOTTLES,
STABBIN' PEOPLE, KILLIN' PEOPLE.
UNH, YEAH--
HOLD UP, NIGGA, I CAN'T HEAR
OUT OF MY LEFT HEADPHONE.
THIS ONE, NIGGA,
THIS IS MY LEFT, TURN IT UP !
WHY YOU DROP
THE BEAT OUT, MAN ?
A'IGHT, HERE I GO.
YOU READY TO
ROCK IT ?
YOU READY TO SEE HOW
WE DO ON THE STREETS ?
ALL RIGHT,
MAKE THAT BEAT DROP.
NIGGA, I SAID DROP,
NOT DRUMROLL.
THE GHETTO,
IT'S UNDERSTOOD WHAT THIS IS,
HOLLA AT YA BOY !
I'M SAYIN', NIGGER,
YOU CAN'T JUST PUT VELVET
IN THE SHIT AND THINK
THEY NICE HEADPHONES !
WHERE'S MY SNARES ?
ONE, TWO, ONE, TWO.
I'MA DROP IT LIKE THIS,
HOLD UP, Y'ALL.
I'MA DROP IT LIKE THIS.
UNH-- HOLD IT.
TURN MY LEFT HEADPHONE
UP A LITTLE MORE.
( man )
IF YOU DON'T KNOW
ABOUT FISTICUFFS BY NOW,
SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH YOU.
HE'S GOT THE ILLEST
JOINT OUT RIGHT NOW.
HE'S CRAZY WITH IT,
"TURN MY HEADPHONES UP."
NIGGA, I'M SERIOUS, I CAN'T
HEAR OUT OF MY LEFT HEADPHONE.
TURN THAT SHIT UP !
OKAY, NOW, LET THAT BEAT
RIDE LIKE THAT.
THAT'S RIGHT, HERE I COME.
I'M GETTIN' READY TO DROP IT,
Y'ALL READY ?
OH, NIGGA,
JUST DROPPED THE BEAT OUT.
OH, HERE WE GO,
HERE'S THE REAL DEAL.
UNH... UNH !
PUMP UP THAT BASS,
PUMP UP THAT BASS !
PUMP IT UP, UNH !
FROM THE--
WHAT HAPPENED ?
OH... WELL, IS THE BEAT
GONNA STOP ?
HIS LYRICS ARE SO TIGHT,
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO RHYME.
AND THE WORD ON THE STREET
IS LATE NIGHT,
ONE NIGHT IN THE GHETTO,
MY MAN GOT SHOT IN HIS EAR
LIKE, EIGHT TIMES.
WHAT ?
NIGGA, I CAN'T HEAR,
TURN UP MY HEADPHONES !
TURN 'EM UP,
TURN THEM SHITS UP !
PUT SOME TREBLE IN IT.
PUT SOME TREBLE IN IT,
THAT'S MY WORD.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO--
HOLD UP, NIGGA,
I NEED SOME WATER.
MY THROAT'S DRY.
WELL, HOW THE (BLEEP)
DO YOU EXPECT ME TO RHYME
IF I CAN'T TALK, NIGGA ?
I'M THIRSTY.
WHAT IS THIS,
JAIL, MOTHER(BLEEP) ?
COP THE ALBUM THAT YOU NEED,
"TURN MY HEADPHONES UP",
IT'S ON
"HEADPHONE RECORDS", BABY.
THERE'S A LOT OF HEAT
RIGHT HERE.
TURN 'EM UP.
TURN THEM (BLEEP) UP.
NOT FOR REAL, NIGGA,
I'M SAYIN' ON THE PAPER,
I'M WRITIN' !
YO, FISTICUFF, IF YOU NEED
SOME NEW ARTISTES, WE DOWN.
I'M KILLIN' PEOPLE,
WE DRINKIN' MALT,
WE BANGIN' CHICKS
WITH NO RUBBERS.
LEFT MY BLING-BLING AT HOME.
WE KEEPIN' IT GANGSTA.
FISTICUFFS !
YOU HEARD, WHAT ?
YOU HEARD ?!
WHAT ?
WHAT ?!
( man )
GO GET THE BIGGEST ALBUM
OF THE YEAR, BABY !